WITH US THIS MORNING HERE ON
"FOX & FRIENDS."
LET’S DO THIS.
LET’S BRING IN FORMER ACTING DHS
SECRETARY CHAD WOLF GOING TO
JOIN US AS WELL AT THIS TIME.
CHAD WOLF.
GOOD MORNING, CHAD.
>> GOOD MORNING.
WILL: WE WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHAT TURNS OUT TO BE THE
BIGGEST LIES OF AT LEAST THE
MOST RECENT NEWS CYCLE.
WHAT’S HAPPENED TO AT LEAST ONE
OF OUR BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND
REALLY THE AGENCY AT LARGE WELL
THE VICE PRESIDENT, VICE
PRESIDENT, AND THE LEADER OF THE
DHS ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS HAVE
PLACED A MASSIVE LIE ON ONE
INDIVIDUAL AGENCY OVER SOMETHING
THAT SIMPLY DID NOT HAPPEN.
FIRST, WE ARE GOING TO PLAY FOR
YOU YOUR INDICTMENT CHAD AND GET
YOUR REACTION.
>> OF COURSE I TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY.
I’M PRESIDENT.
BUT IT WAS HORRIBLE WHAT YOU
SEES A YOU SAW, TO SEE PEOPLE
TREATED LIKE IT DID, HORSES
BARELY RUNNING OVER PEOPLE BEING
STRAPPED.
IT’S OUTRAGEOUS.
I PROMISE YOU THOSE PEOPLE WILL
PAY.
THEY WILL BE -- INVESTIGATION
UNDERWAY NOW, AND THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES.
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
IT’S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
IT’S BEYOND AN EMBARRASSMENT,
IT’S DANGEROUS.
IT’S WRONG.
IT SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE
AROUND THE WORLD.
IT SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE AT
HOME.
IT’S SIMPLY NOT WHO WE ARE.
WILL: IT SIMPLY DIDN’T HAPPEN,
CHAD.
NOBODY WAS STRAPPED.
NOBODY WAS WHIPPED.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, IT’S PRETTY DISGRACEFUL
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
THEY HAVE NULLIFIED THE BORDER
PATROL, THESE PARTICULAR
OFFICERS IN GENERAL.
IT SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
THE SECRETARY SHOULD HAVE THE
BACK OF THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
BORDER PATROL, OF HIS LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
INSTEAD YOU HAVE NOT ONLY THE
PRESIDENT BUT YOU HAVE THE VICE
PRESIDENT AS WELL AS THE
SECRETARY COMMENTING ON ACTIONS
THAT NEVER OCCURRED.
RIGHT?
WE HAVE THE PHOTOGRAPHER WHO
TOOK THE PICTURE.
HE HAS COME OUT AND SAID I
DIDN’T SEE ANYONE GET WHIPPED OF
ANY KIND SO, AGAIN, IT’S JUST
THIS ATTACK UPON LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THE CRISIS
AND TALKING ABOUT THE CRISIS
THAT THEY HAVE CREATED, THAT
THEY HAVE SOLUTIONS FOR.
THEY WANT TO INSTEAD ATTACK LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR DOING THEIR JOB.
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL, DOING IT
CORRECTLY.
BUT, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT,
THE VICE PRESIDENT AND THE
SECRETARY TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY
WILL PAY, WE HAVE GOT TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT IS NOT A FAIR INVESTIGATION
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
AND I THINK WE ALL KNOW WHERE
THIS IS GOING, UNFORTUNATELY.
RACHEL: YOU KNOW, CHAD, THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT JOE
BIDEN HAS RACIALIZED THINGS.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO SAID THEY ARE
GOING TO PUT Y’ALL BACK IN
CHAINS.
ALL USED FOR POLITICAL THEATER.
BUT IT’S ALSO DISTRACTING
PEOPLE, WHEN WE SAW THE
BULLDOZER LOOKS LIKE THE
ENCAMPMENT HAS BEEN CLEARED, WE
KNOW THAT THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
PEOPLE HAVE GONE INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY.
ANOTHER THING WE KNOW AND YOU
KNOW SO WELL, CHAD, IS THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO GOT ACROSS, WHO ARE
NOW IN FLORIDA OR SOMEWHERE ELSE
IN THE COUNTRY OR SOME OF THEM
ARE IN TOWNS IN TEXAS.
AND ARIZONA.
THEY ARE GOING TO COMMUNICATE
BACK TO THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
ARE EITHER IN HAITI OR IN CHILE
OR BRAZIL OR WHEREVER THEY WERE
RESIDING BEFORE AND SAID HEY, IT
WORKED.
WE GOT THROUGH WE WILL SEE MORE
WAVES OF MIGRANTS.
>> WE CERTAINLY WILL SEE MORE
WAVES.
WE ALREADY HAVE REPORTS OF
ANOTHER CARAVAN OF HAITIANS
COMING UP FROM CENTRAL ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THAT POPULATION UNDER
THE BRIDGE IN DEL RIO, ABOUT
9,000 TO 10,000 WILL REMAIN HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE SECRETARY AND OTHERS TALK
ABOUT PUTTING THEM IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS.
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WE NEED
TO KNOW WHEN THEY SAY THAT THAT
MEANS RELEASE INTO THE COUNTRY.
EITHER YOU DEPORT FOLKS RIGHT
AWAY UNDER TITLE 42 OR PUT THEM
IN REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS WHICH
MEANS THEY CLAIM ASYLUM AND THEN
THEY SEE A JUDGE IN A YEAR FROM
NOW.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE FOLKS
ARE BEING RELEASED INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY.
SO WHEN THE SECRETARY AND OTHERS
SAY THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
AND, YET, 9,000 GET RELEASED
INTO THE COUNTRY, IT’S A LIE.
THEY ARE NOT BEING HONEST WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEY ARE
DOING A DISSERVICE.
THEY NEED TO TELL THE TRUTH.
AND THEY NEED TO LAY OUT A PLAN
FOR HOW THEY ARE GOING TO
ADDRESS US INSTEAD OF JUST
SIMPLY DOING THAT FAILED CATCH
AND RELEASE THAT WE HAVE SEEN
DOESN’T WORK.
PETE: YOU ARE RIGHT.
THEY CALL IT SOMETHING ELSE.
THEY CALL IT REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS
ANY SANE AMERICAN GOING TO BE
REMOVED.
NOT DOING AND YELL ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
LET’S HOPE BECAUSE OF PLACES
LIKE THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL PEOPLE
ARE GETTING THE TRUTH AND WAKING
UP TO THE LIES BEING TOLD BY